hello everyone happy holidays the
mindful Club cookbook is finally here
and I feel like a little kid on
Christmas morning because I am so
excited to have my copy in my hands this
book is a compilation of all of my
favorite and best recipes we've got
breakfast we've got soup salads and
sides main dishes snacks entertaining
worthy recipes and of course lots of
dessert so for those you who are ready
to ditch the diet and just dive into
delicious naturally nourishing food this
book is really a no-brainer for everyone
on your holiday list so thank you to
everybody who pre-ordered their book if
you haven't already gotten your copy
you're definitely gonna want to purchase
it today you can go on indigo or Amazon
or of course check it out in your local
book store and as soon as you get yours
please leave me a review I would love to
hear what recipes you're enjoying the
most now today I want to share with you
one of my favorite recipes from the book
this is my beet celery a canned brussel
sprout holiday hash it is so delicious
it's great for entertaining this holiday
season because it's gluten free and it's
vegetarian
and it is packed with holiday cheer so
let's do this
[Music]
to a cast-iron skillet I add some olive
oil over medium heat then add in some
onions and garlic and I give it a good
stir
next I add cooked celery AK and cooked
beets and give that a good stir
next I add some shredded Brussels
sprouts beet greens
lemon zest and lemon juice and I stir it
until those greens wilt down finish it
off with some thyme leaves and set it
aside to make my poached eggs I add a
little bit of vinegar to some simmering
water and then I add in my egg now it's
time to assemble top the hash with our
eggs along with some ground pepper
crushed pistachios goats cheese and some
fresh thyme enjoy
[Music]
so guys I hope you enjoyed this recipe
if you did I don't know what you're
waiting for but definitely please pick
up your own copy of the mindful blow
cookbook I worked so incredibly hard on
this baby and I'm so excited to share
with all of you so please leave me a
comment below with what recipes you guys
are loving I also want to see your
photos on Instagram or Twitter or
Facebook so do not forget to tag me
thank you guys so much for watching and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]